now to lil nas x who's speaking out
again after being shut out of this
year's bet award nominations
[Applause]
[Music]
the star teased a new song on social
media titled late to the party where he
repeats the line f-b-e-t he also
addressed his submission from the
network's award nominees for the second
straight year despite his undeniable
success tweeting the issue is about more
than one specific award show after a
commenter pointed out that he already
won a grammy the rapper responded
wondering how can i get acknowledged by
the most acclaimed award show in the
world and then not even just one
nomination from my own people and when
the openly gay rapper insinuated the
snub could be due to his sexuality
another user compared him to frank ocean
and tyler the creator who have both made
music about having same-sex
relationships nas responded by
suggesting queer men are more respected
when they do less feminine things
as for b-e-t the network released a
statement pointing to lil nas x's
nomination for best new artist in 2020
the statement adds we are committed to
using all our platforms to provide
visibility and inclusion for all of the
many intersections of the black
community